GAYLE?
>> ANOTHER TOUGH STORY THIS
MORNING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH, OMAR.
>>> DELTA'S CEO ED BASTION IS
STRONGLY CONDEMNING GEORGIA'S
CONTROVERSIAL NEW VOTING LAW
AFTER RECEIVING BACKLASH FOR
EARLIER SUPPORTING PARTS OF IT.
THE ATLANTA-BASED AIRLINE WHICH
IS ONE OF THE STATE'S LARGEST
EMPLOYERS WAS THE TARGET OF
BOYCOTT THREATS AFTER BASTION
PREVIOUSLY SAID THE LAW HAD
IMPROVED CONSIDERABLY.
IN A NEW STATEMENT YESTERDAY TO
DELTA EMPLOYEES, HE NOW CALLS
THE LEGISLATION "UNACCEPTABLE"
SAYING IT "DOES NOT MATCH
DELTA'S VALUES."
HE SAID THE ENTIRE RATIONALE WAS
BASED ON A LIE.
THE STATE'S GOVERNOR, BRIAN
KEMP, SAYS BASTION'S STATEMENT
STANDS IN STARK CONTRAST TO OUR
CONVERSATIONS WITH THE COMPANY
AND IGNORES THE CONTENT OF THE
NEW LAW.
ED BASTION JOINS US NOW TO
DISCUSS.
LET'S SORT THIS OUT, ED BASTION.
GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
LISTEN, THE GOVERNOR'S UPSET.
IT'S CLEAR YOU GUYS AREN'T GOING
TO BE GOING FOR JOINT MANI-PEDIS
ANY TIME SOON.
HE SAYS YOU ALL WERE INVOLVED IN
THE DISCUSSIONS ABOUT THE LAW,
THAT YOU NEVER RAISED ANY
CONCERNS ABOUT IT.
HE SAID HE NOW FEELS BLIND SIDED
YOU.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO THAT?
>> WELL, FIRST OF ALL, GOOD TO
BE WITH YOU, GAYLE.
YOU KNOW, IT'S BEEN A
FRUSTRATING FEW WEEKS FOR ALL OF
US HERE IN THE STATE OF GEORGIA.
AS THE PROCESS UNFOLDED, IT WAS
MOVING QUICKLY.
THERE WERE A LOT OF CHANGES.
OUR TEAM WAS IN THERE,
ABSOLUTELY, EXPRESSING OUR
POINTS OF VIEW, MAKING
SIGNIFICANT IMPROVEMENTS TO WHAT
HAD BEEN PROPOSED.
BUT WHEN WE GOT A CHANCE TO
FINALLY SEE IT ALL PUT TOGETHER
AND HAD A CHANCE TO DIGEST IT,
AS WELL AS LISTEN AND HERE IT
FROM THE VOICES OF OUR PEOPLE
ABOUT IT, WE REALIZED THAT THIS
WAS RESTRICTING THEIR ACCESS,
OUR PEOPLE'S ACCESS,
PARTICULARLY IN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY.
AND IT DID NOT -- IT'S IMPORTANT
THAT WE TAKE A STEP FORWARD HERE
IN TERMS OF THE SOCIETY THAT IS
SO POLARIZED.
THE RIGHT TO VOTE IS SACK SANK
AND WE CAN'T SEND THE MESSAGE
THAT IT'S MORE RESTRICTIVE AND
HARDING TO HAVE THEIR VOICE
HEARD.
>> DID YOU NOT KNOW THAT BEFORE?
I UNDERSTAND THAT YOU SPOKE WITH
BLACK LEADERS AND BLACK
EMPLOYEES.
WHAT WAS YOUR MESSAGE?
DID YOU NOT KNOW ANY OF THAT
BEFORE?
>> OF COURSE WE KNEW THAT
BEFORE, AND WE WERE CLEAR WELL
BEFORE THE BILL WAS SIGNED INTO
LAW.
WE HAD PUT STATEMENTS OUT TO
THAT EFFECT.
AND SOME OF THE COMMENTS THAT
WERE MADE WERE TAKEN OUT OF
CNTEXT.
WE WERE NOT SUPPORTING THE BILL.
WE WERE SUPPORTING THE FACT THAT
WE WERE EXITING TOXIC PROVISIONS
OF PROPOSED LEGISLATION.
WHEN YOU PUT IT ALL TOGETHER, IT
DID NOT MATCH WITH WHAT WE SAID
AT THE START WE WERE LOOKING TO
DO WHICH WAS TO ENSURE THAT
VOTER RIGHTS ARE PROTECTED,
THEY'RE SACROSANCT, AND THEY'RE
FACILITATED IN A SAFE AND SECURE
MANNER.
>> MR. BASTION, THE GEORGIA
STATE HOUSE HAS NOW RESPONDED TO
YOUR REVISED STATEMENT OPPOSING
THE LAW, AND THEY HAVE VOTED TO
STRIP TAX BREAKS THAT DELTA
BENEFITS FROM THERE IN THE STATE
OF GEORGIA.
THAT'S A PRETTY BIG DEAL.
I'M CURIOUS, WHAT'S YOUR
REACTION TO THAT?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO RESPOND.
YOU KNOW, THIS IS SOMETHING
THAT'S -- THAT'S MORE THAN
MONEY.
THIS IS ABOUT PROTECTING THE
VOICES OF OUR PEOPLE.
WHEN I SPEAK TO OUR PEOPLE,
PARTICULARLY WITHIN THE BLACK
COMMUNITY, WE'RE HERE IN
ATLANTA, WE'VE GOT A VERY, VERY
LARGE BLACK EMPLOYEE BASE,
ALMOST UNIVERSALLY, THEY ARE
HURT BY THE LAW AND THE
LEGISLATION THAT WAS ENACTED.
AND WE NEED MAKE CERTAIN THEIR
VOICES ARE HEARD.
WE SPENT A LOT OF TIME IN THE
LAST YEAR REACHING OUT TO THOSE
MOST VULNERABLE AND TELLING THEM
THAT WE HEAR THEM, THAT WE SEE
THEM, THAT THEIR VOICES MATTER.
AND IF WE CAN'T STAND WITH THEM
NOW, WHEN WILL WE?
>> YOU SAY THE LAW IS -- IN THE
REVISED STATEMENT -- BASED ON A
LIE AND UNACCEPTABLE.
TO PUT IT SIMPLY, DOES THAT MEAN
YOU WILL WORK TO REPEAL THE LAW?
IS THAT YOUR POSITION?
SHOULD IT BE REPEALED?
>> WE'RE GOING TO WORK TO MAKE
CERTAIN THAT OUR EMPLOYEE VOICES
ARE HEARD, AND ACCESS TO THEIR
VOTE IS PROTECTED AND I
FACILITATED.
BUT OF COURSE IN A SAFE AND
SECURE MANNER.
>> ED, I KNOW WE JUST TALKED
ABOUT THAT YOU HAD CONVERSATIONS
WITH BLACK LEADERS AND YOUR
EMPLOYEES AND THAT KIND OF
HELPED YOU DIGEST THIS LAW AND
COME OUT SO STRONGLY YESTERDAY
AFTER PRAISING PARTS OF THE LAW
ON FRIDAY.
WHAT DO YOU SAY TO CRITICS WHO
ARE SAYING THAT YOU'RE
RESPONDING TO THE THREATS OF
BOYCOTTS THAT FOLLOWED YOUR
STATEMENT FRIDAY WHERE YOU
TALKED ABOUT CERTAIN PARTS OF
THE LAW THAT YOU FELT WERE
BENEFICIAL?
>> WE NEVER SAID THAT PARTS OF
THE LAW WERE BENEFICIAL.
WHAT WE SAID -- WE APPRECIATED
THE TOXIC PORTIONS OF THE
PROPOSED LEGISLATION WERE BEING
TAKEN OUT.
THAT'S WHAT WE APPRECIATED.
AND THAT WAS BENEFICIAL.
BUT IT'S NOT -- THE LAW IN ITS
ENTIRETY WAS NOT BENEFICIAL.
WE NEVER SAID THAT.
WHAT WE -- WHAT WE DO IS WE RUN
OUR BUSINESS.
AND I DON'T RESPOND TO BOYCOTTS
AND -- WE LIVE IN A DIVIDED
TIME.
THERE'S AS MANY PEOPLE PROBABLY
ON THE OTHER SIDE THAT ARE UPSET
WITH ME NOW AS WERE LAST WEEK.
BUT WE WERE CLEAR BEFE THIS
WHOLE DISCUSSION STARTED THAT WE
NEED TO PROTECT THE RIGHT TO
VOTE, AND WE'RE CONTINUING WITH
THAT OBJECTIVE AND WILL CONTINUE
TO FIGHT TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES
HAPPEN AS NECESSARY.
>> WE HEARD ONE OF YOUR
CONVERSATIONS WAS WITH KEN
CHENAULT WHO JOINED US YESTERDAY
TO TALK ABOUT THE LETTER THAT
THEY PUT IN "THE NEW YORK
TIMES."
I WANT TO TALK ABOUT DELTA, THE
AIRLINE, IF YOU DON'T MIND,
BECAUSE I'M LOOKING AT THAT
BEAUTIFUL PLANE BEHIND YOU.
I HEAR THAT DELTA'S NOW GOING TO
START OPENING UP MIDDLE SEATS.
AND A LOT OF PEOPLE ARE
THINKING, NO, DON'T DO THAT.
THE CASES ARE GOING UP.
THAT WAS ONE OF THE SELLING
POINTS FOR DELTA, THAT YOU ALL
WERE LEAVING THE MIDDLE SEATS
CLOSED SO PEOPLE COULDN'T SIT
THERE.
WHAT'S LEADING TO THE CHANGE
NOW?
WHY DO YOU THINK NOW'S THE TIME
WHEN COVID CASES ARE GOING BACK
UP?
>> WELL, GAYLE, AS WE'VE
NAVIGATED THE PANDEMIC, OUR TOP
OBJECTIVE WAS TO MAKE CERTAIN
THAT CONSUMERS FELT CONFIDENT IN
AIR TRAVEL, THE SAFETY OF AIR
TRAVEL.
AND WE ARE DOING THAT.
AND IT'S ALL THE SAFETY
PROTOCOLS, THE MIDDLE SEAT,
CAPPING THE NUMBER OF PEOPLE ON
THE PLANE WERE JUST ONE OF THOSE
STANDARDS.
BUT THE CLEANLINESS STANDARDS,
THE AIR QUALITY,HE FILTRATION
SYSTEMS, ENSURING MASKS ARE
BEING COMPLIED WITH ON BOARD OUR
PLANES.
I'VE INSTRUCTED OUR TEAM TO MAKE
SURE THAT EVERY TIME A CUSTOMER
BOARDS IT FEELS FACTORY FRESH,
YOU'RE JUST STEPPING ON.
THEY'RE DOING THAT, AND
CUSTOMERS ARE TELLING US THAT.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT WHERE THE CASE
COUNTS ARE AND, YES, THERE ARE
CERTAIN PARTS OF THE COUNTRY
THAT CASE COUNTS ARE STARTING TO
RISE A BIT, BUT IN AGGREGATE,
CASE COUNTS ARE STILL RELATIVELY
CONTAINED.
AND MORE IMPORTANTLY THAN THAT,
THE VACCINATIONS ARE SOARING.
40% OF THE U.S. ADULT POPULATION
HAVE BEEN VACCINATED AT THIS
POINT.
WE'RE NOT OPENING THOSE MIDDLE
SEATS QUITE YET.
IT'S NOT GOING TO BE UNTIL MAY.
AND OUR CUSTOMERS TELL US BY MAY
THAT TWO-THIRDS OF THEM BY THE
1st OF MAY EXPECT THAT THEY'LL
BE VACCINATED, AND 75% BY
MEMORIAL DAY.
WE'VE GOT TO RESPOND TO THE
SURGE IN DEMAND THAT PEOPLE ARE
LOOKING TO TRAVEL.
TODAY ACTUALLY WILL BE OUR
BUSIEST DAY POST THE PANDEMIC IN
TERMS OF PEOPLE WE'RE CARRYING,
AND WE'RE CARRYING THEM SAFELY.
WE'RE GIVING PEOPLE MORE
OPPORTUNITY TO FLY ON DELTA THAN
EVER BEFORE.
THAT'S REALLY IMPORTANT.
>> GOT IT.
SO YOU'RE WAITING UNTIL MAY
BECAUSE YOU'RE THINKING MORE
PEOPLE WILL BE VACCINATED.
GOT IT.
HAVE YOU BEEN VACCINATED, ED
BASTION?
>> YEAH.
I HAVE, GAYLE.
I